we are asking people if men can get
pregnant at Columbia University and then
we're gonna go to Harlem and ask the
same question do you guys think men can
get pregnant if you identify as a man
and you have the reproductive parts to
get pregnant then yeah you can get
pregnant like it's a yes obviously yes
there's no other no question someone
that identifies as a man can have a
uterus and and potentially get pregnant
if like the man has the same body
structure like women like women with the
like here maybe he can practice yeah
you're transgender I believe I can do
the whole procedure so you define your
way into pregnancy right
you can now yeah we're the guys in
Harlem I was waiting where's the punch
line show me the base Harlem guy